ja willkommen zu aktuellen Sitzung zum
seminarethik der Digitalisierung heute
haben wir uns ein spannendes Thema
vorgenommen nämlich erstmal ein
Rückblick auf die letzte Sitzung zu
geben da ging es um die Idee des
Internets dann geht es heute um die
Frage was eigentlich künstlich
Intelligenz ist man muss auch noch dazu
sagen künstliche Intelligenz oder
maschinelles Lernen das ist ein
Sonderfall maschinelles Lernen der
künstlichen Intelligenz dann wollen wir
heute ganz zentral auf die Ethik der
künstlichen Intelligenz zu sprechen
kommen darüber wird man auch diskutieren
und es gibt eine Abschlussdiskussion die
wird nicht aufgezeichnet aber jeder von
den zuschauernden kann gerne unten dann
auf Youtube im Verlauf weiter
diskutieren
zum Rückblick der letzten Sitzung wir
hatten es mit dem Internet zu tun das
Internet ist ein spannendes Phänomen die
wenigsten von uns wissen aber genau was
es mit der Geschichte des Internets auf
sich hat das Internet so modernes auch
ist hat schon eine lange Geschichte und
die Geschichte reicht zurück bis ins
Jahr 1969 und da mals hat man in den USA
ein sogenanntes ARPANET entwickelt das
ist ein Akronym das Wort Panne das heißt
advanced research project agency Network
das ist jetzt auch so ein Titel wo man
sich nicht direkt das drunter vorstellen
kann wenn man mal genau hinschaut sieht
man hier research project Network es
geht also um ein Netzwerk was mit
Forschungsprojekten mit
fortgeschrittenen
ja
den Forschungsprojekt auf dem neuesten
Stand zu tun hat darum soll es gehen
also 69 und man muss sagen es war
eigentlich nicht nur ein
wissenschaftliches Forschungsprojekt
sondern es war eine Kooperation mit dem
US-Verteidigungsministerium
zwischen dem Massachusetts Institut auf
technology dem MRT also daher kommen
immer die neuesten Technologien USA
damals zumindest Massachusetts ist ja
Ostküste wenn man heute mal schaut woher
da die meiste Technologie kommt dann ist
es nicht mehr in der Ostküste sind an
der Westküste Silicon Valley aber damals
war es noch
Massachusetts der Staat
dann war das Ziel eine Topologie also
eine raumlogik eines dezentralen
Netzwerks herzustellen dezentral ist
deswegen wichtig gewesen weil man dieser
Zeit sie ändern sich sie haben da
wahrscheinlich noch nicht gelebt ich
auch noch nicht aber es war die Zeit des
Kalten Krieges und da war es natürlich
wichtig eine Infrastruktur zu entwickeln
die möglichst unanfällig ist gegenüber
irgendwelchen Störungen das sehen wir
heute auch wieder es wird immer
wichtiger Systeme zu entwickeln die
nicht an einem einzelnen Punkt hängen
und dann dadurch zerstört werden können
sondern die sich möglichst auf viele
Schultern verteilen das war also das
Ziel dieses Internets damals ist
und seit 1999 89 muss man sagen als seit
den 90er Jahren genau genommen Anfang
der 90er Jahre
hat man mit der Entwicklung des World
Wide Webs begonnen das war ein zern das
ist in Genf ein Forschungsinstitut worum
es eigentlich da geht es um nuklearer
Forschung man sieht wieder es ist
eigentlich aus einem sehr
wissenschaftlichen Kontext heraus
entstanden und da hat der Tim burners
Lee dieses WWW dieses worldwide web aus
der Taufe gehoben
und die Idee war die eines Hypertextes
nicht Hypertext und Hypertext muss es
heißen er hat es beschrieben als white
area hypermedia Information Retriever
initiatives
access to allowedges of dogs also hier
ist schon der Begriff des Universums mit
genannt wenn Sie jetzt an das Metaversum
denken darauf sind meine letzten Sitzung
auch kurz eingegangen da mache ich auch
oben rechts einen Link rein zu einer
eigenen trilogast Sitzung zu Metaversum
dann merken Sie hier ist der Gedanke des
Universums schon ganz eng mit dem
Gedanken des Internets verknüpft also
der die moderne Begriff des metaphiasums
ist hier eigentlich schon so angedacht
ein bisschen warum weil seit 1989 seit
Anfang der 90er Jahre des World Wide Web
sich geöffnet hat nicht nur für
Forschungsinstitutionen sondern für
kommerzielle Interessen aber auch von
Nutzerinnen und Nutzer aber vor allem in
dieser Zeit aus rein kommerzielle
Interesse das habe ich jetzt aus
Wikipedia größtenteil Informationen
jetzt ist aber noch wichtiger die um die
Geschichte des Internets zu verstehen
Web 1.0 Web 2.0 Web 3.0 das sind immer
solche Schlagwörter man kann sich
darunter erstmal gar nichts vorstellen
wir haben gesehen 1989 ist so die erste
Version des heutigen Internets des
worldwide web entwickelt worden und 1991
bis 2004 ungefähr in diesem Zeitraum da
setzt man so das Web 1.0 an das war
einfach nur so eine praktische digitale
Visitenkarte die man da gesehen hat von
verschiedenen Unternehmen nicht nur
Unternehmen auch Institutionen wir
kommen gleich auf noch ein anderes
Beispiel ich habe eine letzten Sitzung
den Spiegel gebracht von 1996 wenn man
das heutzutage sieht dann kann man
darüber lachen aber so waren die Anfänge
also es waren einfach gar nicht
interaktive sehr statische Seiten da war
noch nichts von Dynamik von Interaktion
mit der Webseite möglich das Web 2.0 das
hatte die Idee der das Webs als
Plattform da ging es darum dass man hier
interagieren kann ein gutes Beispiel
ist YouTube YouTube gibt seit 2005
Facebook gibt seit 2004 man sieht also
die großen Plattformen die beginnt alle
so Anfang der 2000er Jahre
das waren so diese interaktiven
Plattformen da waren die Benutzerinnen
und Nutzer nicht nur
Konsumenten von
kommerziellen Informationen sind die
konnten selbst aktiv mitmachen man sieht
es besonders eben bei Youtube das Motto
hieß damals zu Beginn broadcast yourself
also werde selbst zum
Filmproduzenten zu Filmproduzentin und
indem man sich angemeldet hatte auf
Youtube konnte man zugleich kann man
immer noch selbst produzieren und die
Hürde selbst Inhalt ins Netz zu stellen
und nicht nur zu beziehen aus dem Netz
die ist ganz niedrig bei Youtube und das
ist so der Grundgedanke für das Webs 2.0
jetzt gibt es Web 3.0 Web 3.0 ist noch
stärker dezentralisiert sie müssten
Bedenken Web 2.0 wurden nur möglich
durch die Big Tech Industrie also big
Tech darunter zählt man eben Google
Alphabet oder facebook-mitte diese
großen Player die haben die
Infrastruktur
kostenlos zur Verfügung gestellt wie
YouTube haben aber auf der anderen Seite
dadurch natürlich viele Daten bekommen
der Nutzer und Nutzer konnten
Werbeanzeigen schalten wir auf Facebook
es war also eigentlich ein so ein
stillschweigendes agreement zwischen
Nutzerinnen und Nutzern und dem Big Tech
big Tech gibt die Infrastruktur wir
haben die Plattform aber dafür ziehen
sie die Daten aus uns raus das ist so
das Problem auch von Web 2.0 sodass man
sagen kann Web 2.0 hat sich eigentlich
ein ganzes Stück weit gelöst von dem
ursprünglichen Gedanken des dezentralen
Web 2.0 ist ziemlich zentral
zentralisiert
monopolisiert könnte man auch sagen
durch die Big Tech Firmen wie Facebook
und
Alphabet ja das heißt Web 3.0 versucht
an diesen ursprünglichen Gedanken des
dezentralen das ARPANET das der Zentrale
wieder anzuknüpfen und wie will es das
machen das soll erfolgen durch
blockchain Technologie ich habe da auch
mal ein Video dazu gemacht mal oben
rechts einen Link rein was blockchain
überhaupt ist blockchain ist der Gedanke
einer Kette das sind eine Kette aus
verschiedenen Blocks die nicht an einem
zentralen Ort hängt oder eine zentralen
Institution sind zu denen also der alle
Nutzerinnen und Nutzer beitragen also
dann sehr demokratischer Gedanke und das
macht natürlich das Internet viel
weniger anfällig für Machtmissbrauch und
für Konzentration auf wenige Big Player
auch am Bitcoin diese digitale Währung
ist nicht abhängig von einer Zentralbank
wie jetzt der Euro die EZB die
Europäische Zentralbank so eine Bitcoins
als digitale Währung die hängen ab von
einer komplexen blockchain-technologie
also Dezentralität ist hier wieder der
Gedanke deswegen könnte man sagen es Web
3.0 ist so eine Art Synthese also so
eine Art ja
höhere Stufe die vereinigen kann den
Grundgedanken des dezentralen von Web
1.0 und das interaktive und Web 2.0 was
aber durch die Big Tech Player den
Gedanken des dezentralen eben verloren
hat so kann man sich Web 3.0 vorstellen
dazu gehört natürlich noch der Gedanke
des metaviarsums ja also die Integration
von virtueller Realität das ist auch ein
ganz wichtiger Punkt wir kommen gleich
auf die Diskussion zu sprechen ich gehe
noch kurz weiter
dann möchte ich Ihnen jetzt noch das
hier zeigen und da werden sie jetzt
bestimmt lachen was ist das hier
das hier ist sie werden sich glauben die
Adresse bundesregierung.de
wie sie aussah im Jahr 1996 das ist das
Web Archive also wenn sie im Jahr 1996
da waren viele von ihnen nicht geboren
ich war schon geboren aber viele von der
Generation Z den Millennials waren da
noch nicht geboren wenn sie damals auf
die Seite Bundesregierung also die
offizielle deutsche Bundesregierung seit
gegangen sind dann haben sie das hier
bekommen wenn sie das heute gesagt
bekommen würden dass das die aktuelle
Seite der Bundesregierung ist da will
sie sagen ist ein schlechter Witz das
sowas kann jeder zehnjährige jede
zehnjährige kann sich so heutzutage eine
Seite basteln ja geht gar nicht mehr so
simpelde Seite zu passen links ist das
Navigationsmenü mit HTML unten ist noch
so eine impressumsleiste und hier ist
das Zentralfeld wenn sie noch genau
hinschauen auf die Bilder werden Sie
feststellen das ist eine historische
interessante Bemerkung dieses Bild hier
das ist das Bundeskanzleramt in Bonn
also damals war das Bundeskanzleramt
noch nicht in Berlin sondern in Bonn
also so sieht das praktisch aus auf dem
Bild ja so ja und die Bilder natürlich
schlecht aufgelöst und seltsame Sterne
also völlig
völlig veraltet das erlaubt eben dieses
Web Archiv aber archive.org hat eine
Wayback Machine eine digitale virtuelle
Zeitmaschine durch die man sich
zurückversetzen kann in ganz
verschiedene Zeiten des Internets und
das Internet hat eben mittlerweile eine
Geschichte und da sieht man an solchen
lustigen Seiten wie die von der
Bundesregierung wird es noch ein Schritt
weitergehen und kurz noch als vorblicken
angeben um was es heute geht und dann
machen wir eine kurze diskussionspause
also Thema heute Ethik der künstlichen
Intelligenz und was geht es erstmal zu
aktuellen Bedeutung von künstlichen
Intelligenz KI und Maschinen im lernen
dann gehen wir auf die Geschichte von KI
und maschinellem lernen ein Willkommen
auf die Funktionsweise von KI und
maschinellem lernen zu sprechen wir
gehen auf die Ethik der künstlichen
Intelligenz rein und wir fragen uns was
sind Roboter das ist eine ganz ganz
spannende Frage an die sich auch die
Frage nach einer roboterethik anschließt
ja das Thema ist heute der künstlichen
Intelligenz
spannendes Thema obwohl wie auch beim
Internet nicht viele genau wissen was
eigentlich künstliche Intelligenz ist
und darum soll es eben heute erst mal
gehen und die Geschichte und die
aktuelle Bedeutung und die
Funktionsweise bevor wir uns dann
eigentlich mit der Ethik der Intelligenz
befassen können ja erstmal zu aktuellen
Bedeutung von KI und ml macht ml ist
maschinelles Lernen und KI ist
künstlichen Intelligenz das nimmer so
die Abkürzung dafür jetzt haben Sie
bestimmt schon mal gehört also
künstliche Intelligenz wird zunehmend in
ganz verschiedenen Bereichen des Alltags
eingesetzt es geht in Richtung Internet
of things auch die Gegenstände
kommunizieren immer mehr miteinander das
können sie nur aufgrund von künstlicher
Intelligenz spracherkennung ist zum
Beispiel ich komme gleich drauf
Computerspiele wenn sie gegen Computer
spielt Gegner den Computerspielen ist da
immer künstliche Intelligenz integriert
haben und manche sagen künstliche
Intelligenz wird vor allem durch
Computerspiele vorangebracht
ist aber nur so ein Bereich dann gibt es
noch Medizin
Krankheitserkennung Radiologie wenn es
um bildgebende Verfahren geht da muss
man große Mengen von Daten auswerten das
ist ganz ganz wichtig
bildgebende Verfahren dann aber auch
Texterkennung ja wenn man also
zum Beispiel ja etwas Scan mit seiner
App kann dieses Programm sofort den Text
erkennen vielleicht kennen Sie Google
lens das geht noch einen Schritt weiter
da können sie sogar Objekte gleich
erkennen mit ihrem Android Smartphone
dann Spracherkennung ja
Amazon Alexa oder Google ja wenn sie was
sagen wird Ihnen das meistens ziemlich
genau beantwortet man versteht sie
ziemlich gut das System versteht ihre
Sprache ziemlich gut und die Kunst auch
in der Kunst und das betrifft sie jetzt
wahrscheinlich am meisten in der Kunst
wird künstliche Intelligenz interessant
ja Kunst und künstliche Intelligenz sehr
stark eingesetzt und da hat es in der
letzten Zeit ein wirklichen
Quantensprung geben in der Entwicklung
was künstliche Intelligenz und Kunst
schaffen vor allem bildende Kunst
anbelangt da möchte ich jetzt im
Beispiel geben erstmal noch mal alphago
das ist eine künstliche Intelligenz die
ist von Google Alpha
also Alphabet praktisch entwickelt
worden und Go ist ein Spiel ein
Brettspiel was vor allem im asiatischen
Raum
betrieben wird und im asiatischen Raum
ist dieses Spiel go eben besonders
zentral noch komplexer als
und diese künstliche Intelligenz Alpha
go hat es geschafft den besten
Go-Spieler zu besiegen
diese künstliche Intelligenz die jetzt
da Alphabet entwickelt hat kann man auch
mal schön Schach spielen anwenden und
diese KI hat sich so selbst
vorangebracht indem man die KI gegen
sich selbst hat antreten lassen man hat
also zwei künstlichen Intelligenzen
gegeneinander spielen lassen und dadurch
wurden sie trainiert ganz spannend was
ich fast noch spannender finde ist das
neueste da können wir auch mal drüber
diskutieren nachher das ist der E2 das
ist die Beschreibung sagt der IQ is a
new system
also es geht darum
natürliche Sprache ist die natural
language sie geben einen Satz ein also
mit natürlicher Sprache sie formulieren
etwas aus ein Befehl
und aufgrund dieses Befehls
gibt Ihnen dieses System ein Bild aus
was genau so gemalt ist oder designt ist
wie Sie es per Sprachbefehl eingegeben
hat gib ihm jetzt mal ein Beispiel also
ich habe jetzt mal kurz bevor die
heutige Sitzung begonnen hatte ein
folgenden Befehl eingeben Paint und
impressions
also
male mir ein impressionistisches
Ölgemälde das ein Roboter mit einer
roten Blume in seiner Hand zeigt und
jetzt hat mir dieses System durch
künstliche Intelligenz da ist kein
Mensch dahinter direkt folgende zwei
Entwürfe ausgespuckt die sehen so aus
ja besonders spannend fand ich jetzt das
linke das fand ich ziemlich
impressionistisch aber auch das rechte
das heißt Recht ist schon fast
expressionistisch ja wir sehen richtig
die Tupftechnik hier ja das hier hat
richtig dieses also das linke ist viel
impressionistischer schönes sonnenwurf
hier ganz klar die Sonnenseite hier die
Schattenseite ja und das kann man also
in ganz verschiedenen Varianten machen
das ist das ist ziemlich faszinierend
was dabei rauskommt ja der die KI die
dabei eingesetzt wird heißt stable
Diffusion und es gibt jetzt schon ganz
andere Systeme nicht nur der ist sondern
ganz andere wo man das auch kostenlos
machen kann man kann sich der
registrieren und damit ein bisschen rum
spielen also sehr spannend das hat jetzt
natürlich zu einem Aufschrei von vielen
Künstlerinnen und Künstlern geführt die
gesagt haben die künstlichen Intelligenz
nimmt uns unsere Arbeit weg ja es wurde
sogar kürzlich ein von künstlicher
Intelligenz erzeugtes Bild
trainiert hat ein Preis gewonnen ja und
jetzt ist die Frage bin ich jetzt selbst
ein Künstler wenn ich jetzt dieses Bild
hier
anhand dieses Befehls den ich eingegeben
habe
ausdrucken lassen sozusagen vom System
ja und darüber wollen wir jetzt gerade
mal kurz diskutieren bin ich jetzt hier
wirklich eine Künstlerin ein Künstler
wenn ich das eingebe und das System
spuckt es mir aus darüber diskutieren
wir jetzt
ja wir haben gesehen über diese Frage
inwiefern es sich hierbei um
kunsthandelt
inwiefern ich jetzt der Künstler bin der
diese Bilder produziert hat lässt sich
treffen trefflich streiten es gibt
verschiedene Argumente jedenfalls hat
das ganze auch ethische Dimensionen weil
die KI immer auch ihre Basis ihre
Datenbasis aus dem Internet bezieht und
sich dann hier die Frage stellt sind
diese Daten vielleicht auch geschützt
die da zum Trainieren dieses Algorithmus
ist benutzt werden spannende Frage
jetzt geht es aber eigentlich zum
nächsten Thema der Ethik der künstlichen
Intelligenz wir müssen bevor wir uns mit
der Ethik der künstlichen Intelligenz
befassen ein paar Fragen ihres
beantworten nämlich ist künstliche
Intelligenz ein Subjekt ist da je diese
KI die ich zuvor gezeigt habe ist dieses
ästhetische künstliche intelligente
Programm ist das ein Subjekt sprechen
immer so davon der Algorithmus macht das
das Programm macht das es liegt nahe
dass er sich hierbei umfasst eine Person
handelt kann künstliche Intelligenz
Handeln hat jetzt da diese Algorithmus
hatte jetzt dieses Bild gemalt so wie
ich ein Bild malen kann
besitzt künstliche Intelligenz
Intentionalität intentialität bedeutet
eine Absicht eine geistige gerichtetheit
auf etwas ist künstliche Intelligenz
autonom also frei kann sich künstlich
Intelligenz selbst Zwecke und
selbstziele setzen die unabhängig von
mir sind das sind Fragen die uns erst
stellen müssen und die wir klären müssen
bevor wir eigentlich auf die Frage nach
der Ethik der künstlichen Intelligenz
wirklich philosophisch zu sprechen
kommen können jetzt möchte ich aber ganz
kurzen geschichtlichen Abriss bringen
der Geschichte der künstlichen
Intelligenz ich hatte auch gesagt dass
es Internet eine Geschichte hat
mittlerweile und so hat auch die
künstliche Intelligenz eine Geschichte
die ist ein bisschen älter als die
Geschichte des Internets die reicht
ungefähr so und die 50er 40er Jahre
20 Jahrhunderts wir beginnen mit Airline
Turing der gilt so als der Pionier der
künstlichen Intelligenz dann gehen wir
auf John Sir der hat zum 70er 80ern
darüber geschrieben und Hubert drei Fuß
der hat so einen Neunzigern dazu
Interessantes aus philosophische
Perspektive gesagt sie sehen das sind
alles angelsächsische Philosophen einen
Touring war in Engländer Transfer und
Hubert 33 sind Amerikaner und über drei
Fuß ist interessanterweise ein im
Silicon Valley beheimatet gewesener
Philosoph das heißt der hat die
ernsentwicklung dort aus erster Hand
mitverfolgen können ja zum ersten
Philosophen das ist einen Touring sie
haben bestimmt schon mal die
touring-maschine gehört touring-test wir
wollen da jetzt nicht näher drauf
eingehen ich will ihn nur kurz
demonstrieren wie er jetzt künstliche
Intelligenz verstanden hat in der 1950er
Jahren 1950 hat er ein Aufsatz
geschrieben mit dem Titel computing and
intelligence
und er hat das sogenannte
Imitation Game geprägt den Begriff und
er möchte jetzt die Frage ob Maschinen
denken können dass sie eine klassische
Frage die künstliche Intelligenz
betrifft ersetzen durch die Frage der
imaginal digital computers which would
do well in the Imitation game also gibt
es mögliche digitale Computers Computer
die in diesem Imitation Game diesen
nachahmungsspiel gut abschneiden würden
jetzt müssen wir natürlich erstmals
überlegen was ist überhaupt das
Imitation Game von dem man hier spricht
und zwar sieht es so aus ich habe die
Grafik aus Wikipedia
es gibt hier zwei menschliche Personen
B und C und ein Computer das ist dieses
touring-test dieses Imitation Game und
zwar in einem Raum befinden sich der
Computer und die Person B und in einem
anderen Raum getrennt davon befindet
sich die Person C
und die Person C stellt jetzt an A und B
beide gleiche Maßen die Frage ob sie
männlich oder weiblich sind und der
Computer muss jetzt versuchen durch
Imitation die Person C zu überzeugen
dass er Recht hat dass er praktisch
jetzt eine Frau oder ein Mann ist das
ist praktisch die Aufgabe und wenn die
Person C jetzt nicht mehr unterscheiden
kann ob das ein Computer ist oder nicht
dann hat der Computer sozusagen gewonnen
und das ist für Touring so ein Kriterium
dafür ob jetzt Maschinen Intelligenz
sind jetzt kann man sagen ist das
wirklich Intelligenz und der Computer
der simuliert doch einfach nur irgendwas
und der täuscht uns ja imitiert
irgendwas und kann man
imitationsleistung jetzt als Intelligenz
bezeichnet das muss man jetzt offen
lassen diese Frage aber so hat
jedenfalls einen Turing sich künstliche
Intelligenz maschinelle Intelligenz
vorgestellt durch ein Imitation Game ein
Spiel
es geht ja schon die Zukunft wo man auch
gegen Computergegner natürlich spielen
kann der nächste Denker ist schon Sir
der hat 1984 ein Buch geschrieben Mainz
brains ins science und darin hat er auch
die Frage aufgeworfen can Computer think
können Computer denken und er spricht
jetzt nicht mehr so sehr von Maschine
das war jetzt noch bei Alan Touring das
heißt 1984 hat hatte eine ganz andere
technologische Entwicklung schon
stattgefunden ja da waren Computer schon
viel gängiger in unseren Lebensalltag
Lebenswelt eingedrungen und er sagt
jetzt folgendes er verneint diese Frage
ist ein Computer können nicht denken
überhaupt nicht und er sagt folgendes er
sagt Computer haben nur Regeln er sagt
das ist die Syntax also die Ordnung die
Anordnung von Wörtern aber sie haben
kein Verständnis für die Bedeutung
dieser Wörter
Syntax alone ist notificial
Computers in so
Computers have by definition Syntax
alone das ist also der Witz Computer
haben nur Regeln die kennen nur Regeln
können mit Regeln operieren Zeichen
manipulieren nach bestimmten Regeln das
heißt aber nicht dass sie wirklich den
Sinn dieses Wortes verstehen diese
Mantik die Bedeutung eines Wortes there
is no way that system can get from the
syntax
jetzt kann man sich die Frage stellen
bei Deep l wenn ich jetzt irgendwas
eingebe was deutsch ist und es soll ins
Englische übersetzt werden versteht
jetzt die wirklich diese Wörter auf
Deutsch sodass es sie ins Englische
übersetzen kann wie funktioniert das ja
spannende Frage und er sagt noch
folgendes thinking ist more than just in
matter of manecilading meaning the
simbels in den Wolves
contents diese meinte contents are what
we mean by meaning
es geht nicht nur um die
bedeutungslose Manipulation Anordnung
von bedeutungslosen Zeichen 0 und 1 oder
was auch immer sondern es braucht
bedeutungsvolle Inhalte gehalten und nur
diese Gehalte die sind das was Bedeutung
wirklich erzeugen können und das haben
Computer nicht das sind rein formale
Maschinen sagt jetzt schon Sir über die
Computer ja er sagt
ein Computer kann nicht
unser Denken duplizieren einer neues
Denken erzeugen sondern er kann es nur
simulieren ja das Gliedes denkt schon
hier ist between duplications Simulation
es geht nur um die Simulation Computer
tun nur so als ob sie denken könnten
aber tatsächlich können sie nicht denken
das heißt Sie können nicht unser Denken
duplizieren also wir denken und der
Computer denkt auch das wäre eine
Duplikation nein wir denken wirklich und
der Computer der simuliert nur unser
Denken das ist also die These von
transferl Transfer ist auch
hervorgetreten als ein bedeutender
sprachphilosung hat er ganz bedeutende
Arbeiten das heißt und deswegen kennt er
sich auch so gut aus und deswegen
wundert es auch nicht dass er über die
Sprachphilosophie sich der Frage nach
der künstlichen Intelligenz von
Computern
widmet jetzt möchte ich zum Schluss noch
einen weiteren Philosophen nennen dieses
Foto habe übrigens ich von ihm gemacht
auf einem Meisterkurs an der Universität
München
er hat ein Buch geschrieben making on
mind vs modeling the brain orlificial
intelligence back at the branch point
also es geht jetzt um die Frage können
wir Geist erzeugen oder modellieren wir
nur unser Gehirn oder simulieren wir mit
John cial gesprochen nur unsere hier
geht es jetzt um die Frage nach einem
neuen Typus von künstlichen Intelligenz
nicht mehr die Manipulation von Zeichen
die regelbasierte symbolverarbeitung
darauf hatte sich noch transwert bezogen
und Alan Touring jetzt geht es hier in
dieser jüngsten Station um künstliche
neuronale Netze die also unseren Gehirn
nachempfunden sind und über drei Fuß ist
wie auch schon sehr der Meinung nein
Computer können nicht denken er hatte
auch ein eigenes Argument davon dafür
war es von dem Argument von John Sir der
gesagt hat wir können nur Syntax aber
nicht wichtig verschieden ist und man
sieht hier schon 1965 hat wo er drei Fuß
ein Buch geschrieben alchemy and
intelligence als Alchemie das heißt es
geht so ein bisschen ins obskure hinein
dann hier ein sehr treffendes Cover
watch Computers kannst du the limits of
artificial intelligence hier wird ein
Stromstecker gezogen des deutschen
daraufhin diese Geräte sind nicht
wirklich autonom wenn wir den den Strom
nehmen dann denkt da nichts mehr wenn es
überhaupt jemals denkt einfach 1972 und
von 1979 eine Art Nachfolge dieses
Buches Wort Computer still Card do the
limits of order ficial reason also ist
da sehr skeptisch ich habe mit ihm auch
persönlich darüber diskutieren können
über seine Philosophie ein wirklich sehr
sehr origineller Denker und ganz
interessant eine kleine Anekdote 1967
war er der erste Mensch der gegen
Fachprogramm verloren habe nämlich gegen
Mac Hack 6
die Frage war jetzt dieses
Schachprogramm wirklich intelligent das
muss man jetzt dahin gestellt sein
lassen und er sagt jetzt folgendes er
hat jetzt ein ganz anderes Argument für
seine These das Computer nicht denken
können nehme ich er sagt
intelligence has to be maudivated my
purposes in the organizons and goals
picked up by the organism from an going
culture
ja also sagt um wirklich intelligente
zahlen brauchen wir einen größeren
Kontext ja wir brauchen Ziele Zwecke wir
brauchen eine Kultur in der wir verortet
sind wir brauchen einen Körper und das
haben Computer nicht Computer haben
keinen Körper Computer haben kein
Kontext keine Kultur keine
computerkultur in der sie erzogen wurden
sie haben keine Ziele die sich selbst
setzen sie bekommen die Ziele von außen
also heteronomen einprogrammiert und
deswegen können sie nicht denken das ist
jetzt die These anfangs
ja wir müssen uns jetzt Gedanken machen
über verschiedene Formen künstliche
Intelligenz dass wir etwas genauer über
künstliche Intelligenz sprechen bevor
wir auch die Frage nach ihrer ethischen
Bewertungen Zentrum stellen es gibt zum
einen die
symbolverarbeitende KI das ist die
traditionelle KI die kennt man
bei Alan Touring da geht es um
symbolverarbeitung auch bei John ciral
der von Zeichen Manipulation spricht von
bloßer Syntax die keine Semantik kennt
das ist alles symbolverarbeitende KI und
auch deep blue falls sie mal das gehört
haben dieser Schachcomputer der gegen
Gary casparov damals in den 90ern
gewonnen hatte von IBM auch der war
meines Wissens symbolverarbeitend das
heißt symbolverarbeitende KI die
manipuliert Zeichen und verarbeitet
Informationen nach Menschen Regel und
Schlüssen gewissermaßen deduktiv
deduktiv heißt es gibt allgemeine Regeln
und Gesetze und von denen wird dann in
einer bestimmten Hinsicht abgeleitet und
dann bestimmten Perspektive abgeleitet
aber es ist alles eigentlich schon da
gewesen da muss nur noch ableiten so wie
man eine mathematische
Aufgabe löst
Beispiele sind Großrechner
Schachcomputer das ist so die klassische
symbolverarbeitende KI man spricht hier
auch von einem eine Bewegung von oben
nach unten also top-button top sind die
logischen Regeln diesen einprogrammiert
und unten kommt dann das Ergebnis raus
das kommt die konkrete Lösung die
Vorurteile von symbolverarbeitende KI
sind die dass es eindeutig ist und das
alles nach nachvollziehbaren Regeln
fungiert die Nachteile ist es recht
starr und wenig flexibel sie müssten zum
Beispiel bei einem Dieb nun die sind
schachcom Mutter musste man immer neue
Regeln neue Routinen einprogrammieren
noch während des Spiels mit Gary custom
off also recht statisch und nicht so
flexibel die Regeln sind ja auch immer
ganz allgemein
das heißt das System kann nur sehr
schwer lernen es muss sehr aufwendigen
neu programmiert werden das die
symbolverarbeitende KI und der steht die
neuere Entwicklung der neuronalen Netze
des sogenannten Konnektionismus
Konnektionismus bedeutet dass hier die
Neuronen die künstlichen vernetzt werden
und diese künstliche intelligenzte
neuronalen Netze ist das was man heute
auch meistens maschinelles Lernen nennt
es ist nämlich lernen auf Basis von
empirischen Daten nicht deduktiv an dem
allgemeinen zum besonderen sondern
induktiv vom besonderen konkreten
empirischen zum allgemeinen
könnte das auch eine Art von
abstraktionsleistungen wir
generalisieren dieses System
generalisiert anhand von einzelnen
empirischen Befunden belegen konkretere
Regeln die werden abstrahiert induktiv
erschlossen gewisse Maßen dieses System
erschließt sich allgemeinere Regeln ein
Beispiel ist
Google Spracherkennung autonome
Fahrzeuge
sowas ist
ein Beispiel für neuronale Netze
autonome Fahrzeuge habe ich deswegen in
Anführungsstrichen gesetzt weil ganz
autonom sind die Fahrzeuge nicht ja der
Vorteil ist Flexibilität und Lerneffekt
dieses System kann ständig neu reagieren
wenn sich die Datenbasis ändern dann
wird auch anders davon abstrahiert jetzt
muss natürlich auch die Nachteile
eingehen die Nachteile liegen darin dass
es die Ergebnisse nur wahrscheinlich
sind und nicht immer nachvollziehbaren
nachvollziehbar waren die logischen
Schlüsse die ein
symbolverarbeiten das System zieht weil
die sich reduzieren lassen die kann man
nachverfolgen in den einzelnen Schritten
wenn das natürlich sehr komplex ist
hingegen ein künstliches neuronales Netz
operiert sehr sehr komplex wegen der
zahlreichen Verbindungen die wir nicht
mehr überblicken und wie wir auch im
vorherigen sahen können wir nur sehr
schlecht folgen welche konkreten Bilder
jetzt in dieses von mir in Auftrag
gegebenen Bild das impressionistisch
gemeldeten gemalten robots Roboters mit
der roten Blume eingegangen sind also
die Ergebnisse lassen sich nicht mehr
leicht nachvollziehen und es sind nur
Wahrscheinlichkeiten die ausgespuckt
werden weil es eben nur induktiv
operiert und nicht deduktiv nicht mit
absoluter Gewissheit und wir wollen uns
jetzt hier im Folgenden auf neuronalen
Netze konzentrieren weil die am
interessantesten sind philosophisch so
ist es Schema wieder Quelle Wikipedia es
gibt verschiedene Schichten sogenannte
Layer von Neuronen künstliche Neuronen
dessen Knotenpunkte die in mit anderen
Knotenpunkten vernetzt sind sowie auch
unser Gehirne System nach modelliert auf
eine recht abstrakte Weise es gibt
verschiedene
Potenziale die erst überstiegen werden
müssen damit dieses Neuron überhaupt
Informationen weiterleitet
das ist alles wie sogenannte
aktivierungspotenzial so verhält sich es
auch mit unserem Neuronen wenn alle
Neuronen gleich feiern würden weil jeder
kleinsten Regelung dann wer hätten wir
so sagen ein system overload dann würde
bei uns die Sicherung durchbrennen und
genauso ist es auch mit den künstlichen
neuronalen Netzen die werden erst aktiv
wenn eine bestimmte Hürde verschritten
wird so dass nicht jedes Rauschen dort
etwas im Gang sitzt das ist eine
Effizienz Systems und man sieht hier ist
alles mit allem vernetzt ja also das ist
die eingangsschicht ganz links die
eingangsschicht da werden die Daten
eingegeben und dass sie hinten ist die
ausgangsschicht und das hier ist die
verborgene Schicht die sogenannten
hidden layers
und Deep learning nennt man Systeme die
noch eine weitere Schicht haben also die
eine verborgene Schicht haben und noch
eine zusätzliche Schicht und man kann
sich jetzt diese Spalten hier noch mit
viel mehr Neuronen vorstellen nicht nur
drei sondern 10 20 30 und auch noch viel
mehr Schichten sich vorstellen nicht nur
drei sondern 10 20 30 und dann ergibt
sich eine extreme Komplexität der
Vernetzung nun mal dass sie ungefähr so
dieses Schema haben und jetzt bringe ich
ihn mal hier ein Beispiel die sehen
jetzt hier
die Zahl 7 und die Zahl 2 Zahl 2 wird
hier jetzt eingegeben von Hand und die
hat das jetzt hier durch sieben rate
durch durch die layers und hier wird
richtig erkannt hier hinten ja so muss
ich das vorstellen also das ist die
Eingabe die empirische handeingabe des
Handschrift und dieses System soll jetzt
die Handschrift erkennen empirisch und
zuordnen zu einer bestimmten Zahl das
ist dann die Pattern Recognition ist die
musste erkennen das Muster 2 wird
praktisch aufgelöst die Pixeln einzelne
Neuronen und die werden dann
durchgegeben und immer auch wieder mit
Feedback schleif also wenn dann ein
Fehler erkannt wird wenn die zwei nicht
Politik erkannt wird wenn statt zwei
Nummer drei erkannt wird dann wird diese
Fehler rückgemeldet nennt man die
backpropagation und hier sieht man das
mir wird es wieder
zurückgespielt also zurückgespiegelt
die Zuordnung also zum Beispiel falsch
gewesen fünf ist richtig
aber null ist auch richtig hier das ist
korrekt aber hier ist auch noch richtig
viel ist noch richtig aber das nächste
ist falsch und dann passiert
backpropagation betrieben also wird
zurückgebracht der Fehler und dadurch
wird der Fehler minimiert
fehlerminimierungsverfahren
mathematisches Verfahren eigentlich gar
nicht so kompliziert es geht einfach nur
meine Ableitung
dieses dieses Systems um eben ein
Minimum oder maximum ein
gradientenabstiegsverfahren zu entdecken
aber das ganze ist recht empirisch jetzt
wie sollen wir jetzt KI verstehen jetzt
haben wir das gesehen jetzt anhand
dieses künstlichen neuronalen Netzes was
da so alles miteinander in Beziehung
setzen was irgendwie lernt empirisch
sollen wir jetzt künstliche Intelligenz
als Technik oder Technologie als
Werkzeug als Instrument wir hatten
darüber geredet bei der künstlichen
ästhetischen Intelligenz bei derli
sollen wir KI als Medium verwenden mit
dem wir irgendwie auch was tun können
mit uns ausdrucken können sollen wir KI
als Objekt Maschine verwenden oder im
Gegensatz Kaja als autonomes vielleicht
sogar Subjekt bzw Maschinen oder karier
als Prozess KI als Struktur oder was mir
am sympat ist KI als Erweiterung des
Menschen oder genauer gesagt seiner
kognitiven Vermögen das ist so mein
Favoriten es gibt vier problematische
Positionen zur künstlichen Intelligenz
von der wir uns wie mir scheint
abgrenzen sollten gibt die
Ideologisierung also man sagt
KI hat irgendwann Selbstbewusstsein KI
wird die Weltherrschaft erringen das ist
die sogenannte Silicon Valley Ideologie
julia niederröming hat dieser sehr
treffend genannt und gibt es die
anthropomorphisierung von KI und Robotik
wonach dies ganz ähnlich wie die
Ironisierung wir verstehen KI wie
Menschen wir projizieren menschliche
Eigenschaften hinein sprechen wie von
einem Subjekt
Banalisierung ist in meinen Augen
häufiger verbreitet aber genauso
problematisch weil wir es bloß
banalisieren das sagen das ist bloß so
ein technologisches Randphänomen und
Hilfsmittel wie ein Hammer auf einfach
nur ein Hilfsmittel skaliert ich glaube
das greift zu kurz weil KI immer mehr 19
Alltag Eingang findet auch im Sinne der
Vernetzung mit anderen Gegenständen am
Stichwort Internet of things das geht
mit Hammer nicht der Hammer kann nicht
mit dem Amboss oder sonst Instrument
Werkzeug kommunizieren
[Musik]
künstliche Systeme können jetzt
künstliche intelligente digitale Systeme
können das und es scheint mir ein
wichtiger Unterschied zu sein und wir
können KI natürlich auch dramatisieren
und sagen oh je das ist dann gerade
nicht die Banalisierung wir können sagen
oh je damit wird die Welt schlechter wir
müssen die künstliche Intelligenz
stoppen vor ihrem vordringenden Alltag
ist in meinen Augen auch die falsche
anfassungen wir müssen ein reflektierten
kompetenten Umgang mit diesen neuen
Technologien finden die diese vier
problematischen Tendenzen vermeiden
ja und jetzt gehen wir so ein bisschen
zur künstlichen Intelligenz und ihrer
Ethik über also künstliche Intelligenz
habe ich schon gesagt wird immer mehr
Teil unserer Lebenswelt Stichwort
Internet of things die Geräte
kommunizieren miteinander die nehmen
unsere Daten mit auf als Datenbasis und
lernen dadurch sie stehen da
Wechselwirkungen mit uns deswegen
scheint mit der Begriff der
menschenmaschine Interaktion nicht mehr
so ganz angemessen zu sein so redet man
häufig davon also Mensch und Maschine
interagieren aber ich bin der Meinung
dass das noch zu sehr eine Subjekt
objektspaltung zementiert also Subjekt
ist der Mensch und die Maschine ist es
Objekt und ich glaube wir können von
künstlichen neuronalen Netzen nicht mehr
treffen als von Objekt entsprechen wir
sollten eher von Prozessen sprechen
vielleicht sogar von quasi Subjekten
weil es ja eine Rückkopplung hat
also nicht im Sinne eines Subjekts oder
Objekts sind vielleicht eher als Prozess
eine ganz Leistung die wir selbst
anbinden können unsere Leistungen sowie
eine ästhetische Muse so auch eine
intelligente Muse und diese
Intelligenzleistung lässt sich in
verschiedene Bereiche unserer Lebenswelt
integrieren und vernetzen und mir
scheint dass ich die ethik-künstliche
Intelligenz vor allem an dieser
lebensweltlichen Integration und
Vernetzung dieser künstlichen
intelligenten Prozesse bemisst
und jetzt kann man sich fragen trägt
künstliche Intelligenz zu Erweiterung
des virtuellen handlungsraums bei wir
hatten darüber in den letzten Sitzung
gesprochen das Internet der virtuelle
Handlungsraum wie verändert sich diese
Handlungsraum wenn wir künstliche
Intelligenz noch integrieren kann er
sich dadurch vergrößern oder auch
verbessern das scheint mit die
entscheidende Frage zu sein
jetzt habe ich mal den Begriff der
interobjektivität mitgeprägt das heißt
damit ist gemeint wir und dass die
künstliche Intelligenz die interagieren
und zwar so dass wir Menschen die
Datenmengen häufig zur Verfügung stellen
stellen Sie das vor wie die Bilder wir
stellen irgendwelche Bilder ins Internet
und die dienen dann als empirische
Ausgangsbasis für die künstliche
neuronalen Netze wir interferieren mit
dieser künstlichen Intelligenz wir haben
eine Leistung die KI hat eine Leistung
und das das verbindet sich in einer
gewissen Weise
das heißt wir bringen die Gründe und
Ziele mit die KI setzt sich die Gründe
und Ziele nicht wir müssen die Gründe
und Ziele mitbringen aber dazu zur
Verfolgung dieser Zwecke und Ziele
können wir die künstliche Intelligenz
sehr gut nutzen
das heißt diese künstlichen neuronale
Netze die keins die müssen immer von
außen Zielen vorgesetzt bekommen sie
sind deswegen nicht wirklich autonom
sondern nur hypothetisch Ordnung unter
der Bedingung dass sie von außen
einziehen vorgesetzt bekommen ja das ist
so diese
Auffassung die ich gerne zur Diskussion
stellen würde und jetzt haben wir hier
ein paar Probleme die
verantwortungsschreibung von KI wird
immer schwieriger wer trägt denn jetzt
die Verantwortung wenn zum Beispiel ein
Tesla falsch fährt und einen Menschen
umfährt ein Tesla Fahrzeug das man jetzt
vielleicht auch autonom nennen könnte es
geht ja in diese Richtung ist jetzt der
Hersteller der künstlichen Intelligenz
Schuld die Nutzer und die KI selbst
können wir dem System selbst Schuld zu
messen
ich glaube nicht ich glaube wir müssen
immer uns selbst in Verbindung mit der
künstlichen Intelligenz sehen und die
künstliche Intelligenz als eine Art
Erweiterung unseres Handlungsspielraums
verstehen wir sind sehr vernetzt mit ihr
und zwar wie vernetzte als wenn es um
physische Dinge geht deswegen ist aber
auch die Frage nach der
verantwortungsbeschreibung von KI viel
komplexer
wir können sogar dahingehend dass wir
sagen es entwickeln sich irgendwann
kollektive Personen also
personenverbünde und nicht mehr nur
einzelne Personen wenn wir uns mit KI in
einem Bezug setzen
jetzt möchte ich noch anschließend die
Debatte um Roboter erstmal die Frage was
ist überhaupt ein Roboter da gibt es
eine ganz interessante Geschichte des
roboterbegriffs sie sehen diese neuen
Phänomene wie Internet wie künstliche
Intelligenz die haben mittlerweile eine
Geschichte die sind alle so rund um die
100 Jahre alt und genau 100 Jahre alt
könnte man jetzt eigentlich ein Jubiläum
sein ist der Begriff des Roboters so wie
wir heute verwenden nämlich der stammt
aus dem tschechischen Wort Roboter
und das heißt so viel wie Sklavenarbeit
und Frondienst also sehr schwierige
Arbeit die man eigentlich nur ungern
verrichten tut und die deswegen häufig
an die Roboter delegiert werden und wie
häufig
stammen diese Gedanken ersten aus der
Literatur aus der Kunst es gab den
tschechischen Schriftsteller Karel
chapek und der hat für ziemlich genau
100 Jahren 1920 ein Drama mit dem Titel
Rur rossums universal robots das ist
jetzt die englische Übersetzung verfasst
ein Drama und darin geht es um die
dystopische also Dystopie ist das
Gegenteil zu Utopie
Utopie ist in der Regel eine
Zukunftsvision die recht positiv
konnotiert ist mein Wunschdenken und die
Dystopie ist es Gegenteil ist eine
Zukunftsvision die praktisch schwarz
sieht und das eine Dystopie und dieses
dieses Werk rossums
Roberts das handelt eben von einer
Dystopie wonach ein Unternehmen nämlich
Rur so heißt es diese Abkürzung
zum Ziel hat künstliche Menschen zu
erzeugen also Roboter künstliche
Menschen die dann als Sklaven ausgenutzt
werden aber die nach diesen Drama und
deswegen ist es eine Dystopie am Ende
die Menschheit vernichten das heißt die
menschliche Technik wendet sich am Ende
gegen den Menschen selbst das ist ein
jobhaus sowas kommt sehr häufig in der
Literatur vor dass der Mensch etwas
erfindet was am Ende sich gegen ihn
selbst
ja und jetzt will ich ihn mal hier das
Cover zeigen hier das Drama und zusammen
im englischen das Cover aussieht sieht
man schon so ein ja futuristisch
gestalteten Roboter so stellt man sehr
heute vor zur mechanisch für so vielen
so aus Eisen mit irgendwelchen Spitzen
so
Eisenstäben besetzt also irgendwie
futuristisch man erkennt den Menschen
noch so dahinter das hat so ein bisschen
die Form eines Menschen aber es ist halt
doch irgendwas künstliches ja und jetzt
möchte ich auch ein paar Bilder zeigen
aus diesem Drama so sah das aus ja Sie
können leicht erkennen mit der Quelle
Wikipedia das hier sind die Roboter die
haben irgendwelche steife Haltung man
sieht auch hier sitzt eine menschliche
Person und diese Roboter die sind
irgendwie ja wie man sich heutzutage
auch vorstellt wie bei Androiden wenn
sie von Raumschiff Enterprise data der
hat auch noch so ein bisschen was
roboterhaftes obwohl er ziemlich
menschlich wirkt die haben ja so eine
ziemlich ja
unnatürliche steife Haltung so kann man
sich das vorstellen und haben auch so
ein bisschen Ritterrüstungen ja
Metallbeschläge und hier sieht man diese
rechten Szene das hier offensichtlich
jetzt die Roboter sich gegen die
Menschen wenden ja ganz spannende
Geschichte und das erinnert natürlich
weiß nicht wer es von ihnen kennt wir
können darüber gleich noch diskutieren
an Mary Shelleys sehr sehr
berühmten Roman oder Buch Frankenstein
der michelle ist eine englische
Schriftstellerin gewesen in 19
Jahrhundert so sah sie aus und sie hat
in sehr jungen Jahren dieses Buch
verfasst Frankenstein und wenn Sie sich
jetzt mal hier das Cover anschauen
dieses Buches die deutsche Übersetzung
dann sehen Sie unten Frankenstein oder
der Moderne Prometheus das heißt es
knüpft an eine antike sagen an die
Prometheus sage
und hier rechts sehen wir noch eine
Illustration
aus der englischen Ausgabe von
1837 das hier ist der Prometheus der der
Frankenstein genauer gesagt der
praktisch erstellt wurde von einem
Erfinder sie kennen sicherlich die
Geschichte also ein Erfinder möchte ein
Wesen schaffen und dann gelingt es ihm
und dieses Wesen macht sich aber
selbstständig das künstliche Wesen und
wird am Ende sehr gewalttätig warum weil
es nicht verstanden wird weil es von
allen Menschen weil es so hässlich ist
geächtet wird und ausgestoßen wird und
dann wird eben dieses künstliche Wesen
auch
gewalttätig also ganze ganz spannende
Ambivalenz und darin kann man auch schon
irgendwie so Vorläufe der
roboterproblematik entdecken und auch
ganz bedeutend ist Isaak azimov der in
ein Buch geschrieben hat i robot hier
sieht man wieder ganz ähnlich wie von
charpack aus diesem Drama aus diesem
Cover auch hier so hier so ein bisschen
diesen Ritter Ritterrüstung aber dann
auch so ein futuristischen Kopf und die
deutsche Übersetzung heißt ich der
Roboter und so sah Asimov aus und
hassimo hat jetzt in seinem Buch ein
robotergesetze entwickelt und das führt
auch schon ein bisschen diese Richtung
zur Ethik der künstliche Intelligenz er
sagt nämlich in seinem Buch ein
robotergesetz lautet ein Roboter darf
kein menschliches Wesen wesentlich
verletzen oder durch Untätigkeit
wissentlich zulassen dass einen
menschlichen Wesen Schaden zugeführt
wird weiteres Gesetz ein Roboter muss
den ihm von einem Menschen gegebenen
Befehlen gehorchen es sei denn ein
solcher Befehl würde mit Regel 1
kollidieren ein Roboter muss seine
Existenz beschützen solange dieser
Schutz nicht mit Regel 1 oder 2
qualitiert das heißt ein Roboter hat
eine
relative oder hypothetische
unverletztheit und würde könnte man auch
sagen die Arbeit nur dann eben
eingeschränkt wird wenn die menschlichen
Ziele diesen Eigeninteresse des Roboters
übergeordnet sind als ein Roboter ist in
seiner Existenz dem Mensch der Menschen
Existenz mal noch untergeordnet hat das
was von einem Sklave praktisch
isch ganz interessant diese
Regeln die aus seinem Buch meine Freunde
der Roboter und jetzt kann man noch
einen Schritt weiter gehen und sich mal
konkrete Beispiele anschauen die wir in
der jüngsten Zeit auch immer mehr
erleben nämlich letale also tödliche
autonome Waffensysteme die Abkürzung ist
los also es gibt im militärischen
Bereich
Waffensysteme die
automatisiert sind die autonomisiert
sind autonom bedeutet dass die im
gewissen Handlungsspielraum selbst
entscheiden ohne dass da eine Person
irgendwie was steuert wir haben eine
Handlungsspielraum und gewissen Rahmen
und jetzt kann man sich eben fragen ob
das auch in militärischen Kontexten
ethisch verantwortlich ist
gerechtfertigt ist das Waffensysteme
selbst entscheiden wen sie jetzt töten
oder nicht dürfen das autonome
Waffensystem ist das legitim selbst im
kriegszusammen oder nicht wie gab es in
der Zeitschrift FX sind international
affairs einen Artikel mit dem Titel
Terminator Asics should wie Bayern
Killer robots und hier sieht man jetzt
so ein Roboter wie man sich den
vorstellen kann da sieht man jetzt gar
keine menschliche Form ist einfach ein
Kettenfahrzeug und hier sind irgendwie
Sender Empfänger und hier ist das
Waffensystem montiert darauf ja und
jetzt kann man die Fragen dürfen wenn
diese Systeme semiautonom funktionieren
dürfen die dann überhaupt auch in
kriegskontexten eingesetzt werden ist
das verwerflich
und jetzt kann man hier noch
unterscheiden zwischen Robert heißt
military Systems sind RMS die sind immer
bei denen sind immer Menschen in den
Entscheidungsprozess unmittelbar
involviert ja die können zum Beispiel
ferngesteuert sein oder Drohnen sind
sowas zum Beispiel ja da stehen Menschen
dahinter die die Verantwortung
übernehmen welches welchen Menschen oder
welches Ziel jetzt dieses System
angreift und die Liebe autonomos weapons
systems sind keine bei den sind keine
Menschen mehr in den
Entscheidungsprozess unmittelbar nur wir
die sind irgendwie autonomen
teilautonomen zumindest ja und jetzt ist
die Frage über die wir diskutieren
müssen folgende ist es inhärent falsch
wenn diese Lars diese Liebe und rappen
Systems Menschen töten weil diese
getöteten Menschen selbst im
kriegszusammenhängen dadurch
instrumentalisiert und zu bloßen
Objekten eines Roboters integradiert
werden macht es einen Unterschied ob
jetzt ein anderer Soldat der ähnlichen
Armee von einem RMS getötet wird oder
von einem Labs
ändert sich der moralische Status eine
Handlung wenn Menschen mit RMS oder Lars
getötet werden macht es einen
Unterschied ob dieses System jetzt
autonom war oder von Menschen
kontrolliert war
für diese Frage wollen wir jetzt
diskutieren
es ist interessant dass die Problematik
der laws dieser Lieder autonomes weapon
systems auch im Völkerrecht
benannt wird nehme ich in dem
Zusatzprotokoll zu den Genfer Abkommen
das ursprünglich vom 12 August 1949 war
und dieses diese Zusatz ist eben 1977
gewesen und da steht im Artikel 36 neue
Waffen und das betrifft jetzt eben auch
diese Lars jede hohe Vertragspartei ist
verpflichtet bei der Prüfung Entwicklung
Beschaffung oder Einführung neue Waffen
und neue Mittel oder Methoden der
Kriegsführung festzustellen ob ihre
Verwendung stets oder unter bestimmten
Umständen durch dieses Protokoll oder
durch eine andere auf die hohe
Vertragspartei anwendbare Regel des
Völkerrechts verboten wäre das heißt man
muss jetzt immer auch reflektieren ob
neue Technologien ob die eben da noch
darunter passen das zeigt wie die neuen
Technologien die bringen ganz neu
Probleme mit sich und eben auch die
künstliche Intelligenz in diesem Sinne
ja das war's wir haben viele
diskussionsfragen behandelt inwiefern
können KIS und Rob behandeln wer trägt
die Verantwortung für handeln die
programmierenden oder die Systeme selbst
inwiefern ist es problematisch wenn im
Krieg autonome Waffensysteme eingesetzt
werden das haben wir diskutiert in den
nächsten Sitzung geht es um den
transformanismus das ist eine
interessante philosophische Auffassung
die These vertritt dass sich durch die
neue Technik vor allem die künstliche
Intelligenz die Digitalisierung eine
neue Evolution ergibt nämlich von Mensch
und Technik bisher so der Post
humanistische Tenor hat sich nur die
menschliche Evolution natürlicherweise
vollzogen bis hin zum Homosapiens jetzt
zur die These beim 21 Jahrhundert wird
auch die Technik der Evolutionstheorie
unterliegen und mit den Menschen
verschmelzen so dass die Technik
irgendwann selbst das selbst ein
Bewusstsein entwickelt take Butter die
intelligent werden und es gibt
Popularität und das ist eben ein Zustand
wo die technologische Entwicklung so
rapide stattfindet dieser Prozess so
steil ansteigt dass irgendwann
Selbstbewusstsein auch bei Maschinen
energieiert dass da was ganz Neues
passiert und das ist ein sehr spannende
Thematik die was utopisches und auch
dystopisches hat und darüber reden wir
dann in der nächsten Sitzung vielen Dank
für die Aufmerksamkeit und ich bin
gespannt auf die Diskussion auf YouTube